[Music]
let's go to elizabeth and michael in
twin cities twin cities
minnesota what's up guys
hello
hello what's happening
oh well it's finally above zero i was
going to say
how cold is it there one
is it so cold it's four like four today
four degrees that's unconscionable and
it's been negative for a while
as a kid who grew up in texas that just
seems like
i know there you know
the the whole story about hell is it's
hot that i can't imagine living in a
place where it was negative that seems
like hell to me is it is it not
um you get used to it i guess just kind
of get used to it it's a dry cold or i
don't know whatever they say right cali
all right so uh what's up with you two
how can i help
well um
we've just uh recently started dating
and uh
within a space where uh
i have uh kids from a prime elite
two young kids five and nine
and uh
and uh and she does not
so
becoming
into this from different places
right for me the uh
the kids and and what's best for them is
super important yeah
and i kind of feel like when we talk
about this we're both a little clueless
on how to proceed
um
i
feel like my kids have had enough to
remind their lives from uh
from dissertation with their mom
and
i want to do what's best for them
but i don't really know how to navigate
that yeah
and and
kind of let you speak for yourself and i
know that you're coming from your own
space yeah i'd love to hear your side of
this elizabeth
um so we've been dating for a while
like how long is a while
about five months now okay
um
and like him i'm clueless
really want to do things the right way
and set kind of you know
have a relationship that can be a model
for a healthy adult relationship
but
don't know what that looks like or where
to start when i don't have kids so you
know dogs and cats are much easier
dude somebody bought me a mug
brad
bought me a mug and just says cat dad on
it it's incredible
not a thing elizabeth not a thing um so
first i want to applaud both of you for
wanting to do this thing right on behalf
of these two little ones um most times
i'm talking to folks there's a
selfishness there that they just need to
figure out themselves because i gotta be
me and blah blah blah
and you two sound like you are
really thoughtful human beings and so i
wanna applaud you for that that's
awesome
um okay so we can get into this a little
bit but
i'm gonna ask some awkward questions
that y'all may not be ready to answer
in front of a couple million people is
that cool
that's fine and so y'all y'all um
the two of you i'll frame these
questions as things you can answer now
or later and you can just feel free to
say uh later and y'all can talk about
this on your own is that cool
interesting
um all right so michael you mentioned
that their kids were traumatized by
previous mom does previous mom believe
this
is she would she be telling me if she
called my show would she be telling me
that their dad's nuts and whatever or is
there some clear
you know challenges with mom
um there's some clear challenges with
mom she has um diagnosed mental health
she was to a certain extent okay so do
the kids have contact with her
they do i mean i i don't want her to
sound like an absolutely crazy person
she's not but she does have some mental
health challenges sure but she
she also wants the best for the kids but
uh
but let's just say it ended up with a
lot of trauma that was infected on the
kids sure there you go and then how long
have you been separate from her
separated from her um
two and a half almost three years now
okay okay so three years has she started
dating again
no
do you two
have you all talked about this have you
all had this conversation
here's how we're going to approach this
if one of us starts dating
or here's how we're going to decide who
else is around our kids have y'all had
that conversation or is that a no go
with the kid's mom no yeah
uh and that's that's also a non-starter
like there's no communication between us
okay so that conversation would never
happen okay all right
um
in elizabeth tell me what you think
about this michael guy how'd you meet
him
online
uh he's pretty great yeah
takes care of kind of everyone in his
life and
funny smart
responsible cute
i was going to say is he handsome all
right good
very what what uh
very gross gross
um what
what is it about him
and these two little ones that makes you
think i want to get deeper into their
world
he's incredible and from everything i've
seen about the two girls they're pretty
incredible too um
i really want a family and i could see a
really
amazing uh kind of joyful building life
future there
okay
so here's kind of the global rules um if
you will not there's not really rules i
guess but the global recommended
practices are
whenever you get divorced but if you get
separated um
and this is different than if somebody
passes away
wait at least a year
right so you've done that it creates
some space between
this and that the second thing that i
think is important for everybody to
understand is sometimes these kids will
feel like
they are
having to choose sides and so there may
be moments where elizabeth if they're
nice to you they will feel like they're
betraying their mom
even if their mom is totally supportive
and wonderful it's like no daddy's this
is she's a great you know this daddy's
new girlfriend elizabeth is awesome but
that we put these kids in this situation
so you're gonna have to go into this
knowing
that
the things that a five-year-old and a
nine-year-old say to me over the next
one year two years ten years
are not going to be personal it's gonna
be them working out which side am i on
which team am i on who do i like does
that make sense
yeah
um
and then the the big challenge i have to
you two is this
um
michael tell me about elizabeth what
makes what makes elizabeth worth getting
back into this game that that hurt you
and your kids last time
i guess created your kids there's that
but
well i mean
i don't know where to start i mean she's
just amazing
she
she represents a lot of things that i
never that actually like i never had in
my life a partner who is very
level-headed
um
very focused
very supportive
um
the time we spent together she
she is completely in sync with
everything that we do she she works with
me
on pretty much anything that we
want to do
i don't know i feel supported i feel
like i'm with an actual partner not
someone that i have to carry along
um
she looks amazing
[Laughter]
come on michael
no but uh seriously i mean i see like
most of my life i carry people along
and
when i'm with someone that doesn't need
to be carried and is willing to uh
shoulder up with me
but it's a pretty different feeling i've
never quite felt that way before
so
that's awesome that's awesome so the one
the one hang up i have with all this is
this is the five month number
and
the question you all have to ask each
other is this
we've known each other for five months
um
he's so cute
she looks amazing
she's a great partner um he is caring
and all these things
um
is there legs beyond five months
and
i changed my mind i won't ask all that
publicly y'all can answer that on your
own
make sure you and this is i'm talking to
you michael make sure you are
see some legs on this thing
before you introduce her to your
daughters
and i would start with this is daddy's
new friend
and go to this is daddy's special friend
and that will take a period of weeks and
a period of months and elizabeth you're
going to feel like you are being hedged
at some point
or it's going to feel like it's what you
feel like it's going to feel like you're
dating a guy
and he won't invite he won't introduce
you to his friends like at the bar he's
like hey i want you just to sit over
here and go talk to my buddies and
you're gonna be thinking i wanna go meet
your friends why are you hiding me it's
gonna feel like that a little bit and
you're gonna have to be really
level-headed and really um you're gonna
have to get your needs met somewhere
else
does that make sense
yep and to be clear when we're talking
about this it's pretty future looking
it's not like in the next month yeah i
got you i got you um
but you are gonna have to you're gonna
want to do things because this is
natural i would if i was you
i would want to do things that would
assure that these girls love me i want
to help them with their hair i want to
help them with school i want to talk to
them about deep things i want to go
shopping with them
and there's going to be some
really careful baby steps into this
where they invite you into these
conversations so you're going to be
creating a world where they feel safe
enough to come to you
but when you force them into hey i want
to talk about this or tell me who you
have a crush on
them bam now you're forcing them am i
choosing her or my mom right does that
make sense and that's gonna be hard hard
hard and so frustrating
so frustrating and then one day they'll
come to you and be like
can you not gonna believe this this boy
wants to kiss me or i found somebody at
school i'm in love with whatever you're
gonna talk about it's gonna be deep and
you're gonna go to bed and you're gonna
tell michael you'll be like oh my gosh
they trust me it's gonna be so great and
the next morning they're not gonna talk
to you because they're gonna feel
ashamed that they
betrayed their mom right it's gonna be
this back and forth thing that happens
and michael they're going to want you to
be happy because you sound like an
amazing father they're going to want you
to be happy and lovely and oh my like i
can't believe dad is doing this and who
knows what mom's going to say right
so it's just expecting that you're gonna
have a picture that this is all gonna
work out perfect and it might in a long
game it's just gonna be hard
and maybe none of this happens maybe
your daughters are amazing you've they
are just understanding and they're like
dad you deserve to be happy and mom's a
little whoa
and
like we are really excited and i've seen
that before too so it's being honest
honest honest and making sure hey we're
in this for the long haul and then a
slow
slow introduction
not hey this is dad's new girlfriend
she's moving in
uh girls y'all are going to be bunking
up because like that would be traumatic
yeah right and you all know that you all
know that
um michael so is elizabeth it
i'm sorry could you say it again is
elizabeth it
i'm making it weird now i'm so excited
even kelly looked up and she's like
do
what liz is it oh gross liz is
hey y'all get married here in the studio
that'd be so great
let's figure that out um but yeah hey i
i'm fully in support of of y'all having
this conversation for those listening
the broader conversation you got to
waste some time you can't get a divorce
and then start dating somebody a month
later and introduce them to your kids as
hey this is daddy's boyfriend or this is
daddy's girlfriend or this is whatever
you can't do that you got to give these
kids some space because it it
it uproots everything in their life
the second thing is by the way not a new
mommy either elizabeth not a new mommy
they've got a mom right and
unless there's somebody passes i mean
they don't have a mommy
understand that kids may view friendship
or connection or
like i'm gonna start calling you mom
they they're gonna have this betrayal
feeling that's gonna be deep deep deep
and oh my gosh
wait until there's a level of commitment
till i think this is serious
because then the
girls will feel the sense of trust and
okay we're going to trust again and then
if y'all break up
man now they're back into well we lost
somebody else that we could lean into
and trust and now it's just us and dad
and dad sounds great but man that's hard
on kids hard on kids hard on kids
and i recognize moms and dads that's not
fair that these are none of this is fair
these are your kids
and they always always always come first
their trauma comes first let me put it
that way i think we over put our kids
first on a lot of other things but when
it comes to relationships their safety
and their trauma especially that they
experience in divorce comes first before
your need to
let's go out to the club
stop
take care of your kids